Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans ScienceClic,
les mathématiques de la relativité générale,
partie 7, l’équation d’Einstein.
Notre modèle mathématique est terminé.
D’une part, on sait décrire une géométrie
d’espace-temps, et notamment sa courbure,
et en déduire la façon dont se déplacent
les objets grâce à l’équation des géodésiques.
On a pour cela développé tout un tas d’outils
mathématiques, comme le tenseur métrique,
les symboles de Christoffel, ou encore les
tenseurs de courbure, de Ricci, et la courbure
scalaire.
D’autre part, on sait également décrire
le contenu énergétique de l’univers, et
ainsi les objets et les astres qu’il contient,
à l’aide d’un seul outil, le tenseur
énergie-impulsion.
L’idée la plus puissante en relativité
générale, va être de relier ces deux notions.
A l’aide d’une seule équation, on va
écrire une égalité entre d’une part la
courbure, et d’autre part le contenu de
l’univers.
Cette équation qui se présente comme une
égalité entre la géométrie et le contenu
de l’univers est ce qu’on appelle l’équation
d’Einstein.
Dans notre modèle mathématique, l’équation
d’Einstein est l’unique équation qui
ne se démontre pas.
C’est une équation que l’on admet car
elle semble parfaitement correspondre au monde
qui nous entoure.
Cette équation renferme toute la qualité
prédictive de la relativité générale,
elle permet de relier directement le modèle
mathématique, abstrait, à la réalité concrète
des astres dans l’univers.
Habituellement l’équation d’Einstein
prend la forme suivante.
Sous cette forme, tous les termes à gauche
de l’équation représentent la géométrie
de l’espace-temps.
On y trouve le tenseur de Ricci, la courbure
scalaire, et le tenseur métrique.
Le terme à droite de l’équation correspond
quant à lui au contenu de l’univers, il
s’agit simplement du tenseur énergie-impulsion,
que l’on multiplie par une certaine constante
qui détermine l’intensité de la gravitation
dans l’univers.
Cette constante dépend de la vitesse de la
lumière, et de la constante de gravitation
de Newton.
Elle est ici pour s’assurer que la relativité
générale donne bien les mêmes prédictions
que Newton dans des cas de faible gravité.
Il est très important de comprendre que l’équation
d’Einstein est extrêmement complexe à
résoudre.
En effet, comme on l’a vu précédemment,
le tenseur de Ricci et la courbure scalaire
qui interviennent à gauche de l’équation
renferment des calculs complexes de dérivées,
de sommes, et de produits du tenseur métrique.
De plus, les deux côtés de l’équation
sont intimement liés.
Le contenu de l’univers va influencer la
courbure de l’espace-temps, mais réciproquement,
la courbure de l’espace-temps va à son
tour influencer le mouvement et l’évolution
des astres.
Résoudre un problème aussi intriqué est
pratiquement impossible.
Dans la plupart des cas il est donc nécessaire
de faire des approximations numériques et
des simulations informatiques pour résoudre
de tels problèmes.
Dans l’équation d’Einstein, la courbure
de l’espace-temps est incarnée par le tenseur
de Ricci et la courbure scalaire, qui en est
la contraction.
Mais dans un espace-temps comme le notre,
à quatre dimensions, l’équation d’Einstein
possède une symétrie très intéressante.
L’équation reste vraie si l’on interchange
le tenseur énergie-impulsion avec le tenseur
de Ricci, et que l’on inverse la constante
d’Einstein.
Cette nouvelle expression est complètement
équivalente, et on verra par la suite qu’elle
peut être plus simple à utiliser.
L’équation d’Einstein est très complexe,
mais elle accepte quand même un certain nombre
de solutions exactes.
La solution la plus simple, et la plus utile,
est la suivante.
Imaginons un univers vide, dans lequel on
place un astre massif, de masse grand M.
On suppose que cet astre est sphérique, statique,
c’est à dire qu’il n’évolue pas au
cours du temps, et qu’il ne possède aucune
charge électrique, ou propriété magnétique.
Cet astre peut représenter une étoile comme
le Soleil, ou bien une planète comme la Terre.
Notre objectif est de calculer le tenseur
métrique, et donc la géométrie de l’espace-temps,
en un point à l’extérieur de l’astre.
Tout d’abord, choisissons un système de
coordonnées.
On choisira d’observer le point depuis une
très grande distance, et de mesurer le temps
sur notre horloge, t, la distance entre le
point et le centre du repère, r, et deux
angles, theta, et phi.
Notre point se situe dans le vide.
Par conséquent le tenseur énergie-impulsion
y est nul.
Grâce à la deuxième version de l’équation
d’Einstein, on en déduit que le tenseur
de Ricci doit également être nul.
Pour déterminer la métrique à partir du
tenseur de Ricci, les calculs sont fastidieux
et nécessitent de résoudre de multiples
équations différentielles.
Mais grâce aux différentes symétries et
invariances du problème, il est quand même
possible d’obtenir son expression exacte.
On l’appelle la métrique de Schwarzschild.
La métrique de Schwarzschild dépend de la
masse de l’astre.
En particulier, si la masse vaut 0, on retrouve
la métrique de Minkowski, qui décrit un
espace-temps vide.
Mais autour d’un astre comme la Terre la
métrique de Schwarzschild nous indique que
l’espace-temps se courbe.
Plus on se rapproche de la planète, plus
la courbure devient importante.
Dans le cas d’une planète, sa surface va
nous stopper, et en son intérieur, la métrique
de Schwarzschild n’est plus valide.
Mais dans le cas d’un astre suffisamment
compact, dont la surface est très proche
du centre, on va pouvoir se rapprocher suffisamment
pour atteindre une distance à laquelle le
terme temporel de la métrique vaut 0.
On a atteint un point de non-retour, le temps
est dilaté à l’infini, c’est le rayon
de Schwarzschild, l’horizon d’un trou
noir.